thank you this is Susan represent of
Susan L knee of Lebanon from the House
Ways and Means Committee I find that due
to the state of emergency declared by
the governor is the result of the Kovan
19 pandemic and in accordance with the
governor's emergency order number 12
pursuant to executive order 20 2004 this
public meeting is authorized to meet
electronically please note that there
are no physical okay there is no
physical location to observe and listen
contemporaneously to this meeting which
was authorized pursuant to the
governor's emergency order however in
accordance with the emergency order I am
confirming that we are any providing
pode access to the meeting by telephone
with additional access possibilities by
video or other electronic means we're
utilizing zoom for this electronic
meaning all members of the committee and
select legislative staff have the
ability to communicate contemporaneously
during this meeting through this
platform and the public has access to
contemporaneously listen and if
necessary participate in this meeting by
clicking on the following website
address HTTPS / / w WS / j / 92 61 30 36
5 3 2 or dialing one of the following
phone numbers 1 9 - 9 205 six oh nine
nine four one three oh one seven one
five eight five nine - providing public
notice of the necessary information for
accessing the meeting we previously gave
notice the public of the necessary
information for accessing the meeting
including how to access the meeting
through using zoom or Tofana CLE this
information is printed in the house
calendar C by providing a mechanism for
the public to alert the public body
during
the meeting if there are problems with
access if anyone has a problem please
call six zero three two seven one three
six zero zero or email ages and houses
and committee s and services and the G
dot state n H dot us d a-- during the
meeting if the public is unable to
access the meeting in the event the
public is unable to access the meeting
the meeting will be adjourned and
rescheduled I want to introduce the
staff that are in the meeting assisting
us Jen for house community researcher is
the meeting house additional House
committee services staff providing
support our Brad Greenland Pam smiling
and Christina Dyer this is an executive
session on HP 1563 FN & HP 1627 FM the
Ways and Means Committee held a public
hearing on HBC 1563 FN March 4 and a
public hearing on HB 1627 and then March
5 both their second committee bills and
had to be withdrawn from the earlier
executive session for further work
copies of the bills and other relevant
materials have been posted on the main
page of the General Court website under
the heading remote meetings please note
that all votes that are taken during
this meeting shall be done by roll call
vote let's start the meeting by taking a
roll call attendance when each member
states their presence please also state
whether there is anyone in the room with
you during this meeting which is
required under the right to know law
please Malloy call the roll
representative Eames oops
do we not have represent guess we have
him you're muted he knows no okay yeah
I'm present I met my almond Jeffrey and
I'm alone or static Eric my dog
Southworth I'm present at my home in
Dover and I am alone
clerk is present at home in Greenland
and his alone representing Schamberg I'm
in wilmut and my wife is in her office
it's an executive Tucker I'm in Randolph
and I'm alone excited bunker I'm at home
and Exeter my wife is in and out of the
room I'm listening on headphones
representative gum Marlowe I am home and
Swansea and I'm by myself presentative
Griffith I am here I'm actually in
Falmouth Massachusetts at work and
coworkers are in and out oh wow
representative Lachman
that is Stringham I'm here in Lincoln
New Hampshire by myself
representative major
represent a major represented made here
you may have to respond to a prompt on
your screen okay I'm here in Plaistow
and by myself
representative Griffin a Mary Griffin at
home and wind him in alone episode of Oh
Larry almond Hudson by myself
representative bra me representative
Lang absent of Lang you're muted
requestors unmute I haven't done
response he may not have showed up again
yet representative Doucet I'm present by
myself now in Manchester at my officer
representative Edwards
I'm representative Edwards I'm at home
in Auburn New Hampshire I have two dogs
and my wife running in and out of the
room ever said of bursting out in
Hampshire and representative all me I'm
home alone in Lebanon which one of the
prettier parts is behind me that
represented Malloy I'm sorry to
interrupt but it appears that
represented playing is live again if you
would like to call his name again
representative Lang representative
layman Saratoga Springs New York and I
am alone
that's the roll call thank you um we are
up to 19 this time so we're going to
take these bills in numerical order on
house 1563 F and relative to the use of
funds in the drug forfeiture fund uh I'd
like to ask for a motion from represent
of Southwest represent L me I'm
apologize for interrupting but I just
noticed that representing Woolery had
raised his hand before you started your
last statement oh no key wanted to take
him or is this about procedure or
something don't know i'm sanna glory i
just wanted to know who gets their prize
for the longest distance call recognize
Southworth for a motion on 1563 FN
relative to the use of funds in the drug
forfeiture fund thank you I'd like to
make the motion of interim study
HP 1563 and speak to my motion thank you
can I have a second represented stream
did you just raise your hand yeah I'll
second that
thank you okay for the motion we had a
work session and we had many questions
and really the questions led to other
questions so we need more time to
resolve some of the complications of
this bill also we want to request an
audit of the funds thank you if I could
clarify the audit would be a performance
audit we have to do a formal request
from the committee chair to the
committee which for the performance
audits which doesn't have a meeting time
scheduled yet but which should be
meeting sometime later this summer and
and I hope that we can actually get them
to to do a performance audit of the
transparency with which the funds are
used it is actually written into the law
about the drug forfeiture fund thank you
any further discussion of this bill
representative Tucker had her hand up
yes I wanted to thank the proponents of
this bill for bringing it the whole
issue forward because it didn't turn out
as we looked at it to it but it was a
much more complicated topic than we had
realized or that I had realized and so I
think they certainly performed a great
service to us to open up an examine
small section of state operates
and I'm grateful for that thank you any
further represented bursting thank you
I'd like to thank representative
Southworth for his motion and Springer
spring them for his second I know we
have a lot of common ground in this bill
and I know they're readily acknowledged
and I look forward to working with the
other side thank you thank you any
further discussion I don't see any more
hands up well then the clerk will call
the roll on on interim study for House
bill 1563 FN representative Ames yes
representative Carrick yes
represented Southworth yes
clerk votes yes Schamberg yes
representative Tucker yes
representative bunker yes represented
Gamora yes
representative Griffith yes
representative Stringham yes
representative major yes
representative Griffin yeah represent
avala reading yes presented a Brahmi yes
representative Lang yes representative
just said yes representative Edwards yes
miss native Burstein yes
representative all me yes boat is 19 yes
zero knows vote 19200 spell 1563 FM to
go into interim study on the motion
passes on is there any objection to
consent not hearing any on I will offer
it for the kids
thank you on the other bill sentence we
have to deal with today his house bill
16:27 FN creating an animal records
database and I want to move but to pass
on the bill can I have a second jabbing
but that was episode of Griffin and now
I would like to move amendment this
amendment
last night there it is the emember
dated May 22 because there have been a
sequence open 12:54 H 2 H P 16 27 FN is
there a second Romney is waving his hand
I think you need to say something can
you unmute if you mean to second it
thank you
okay so if I can speak to my motion the
creation of this database is the year's
highest priority for the Department of
Agriculture its limited staffing means
it has not been able to get copies of
vaccination records which are held only
at town halls and needed quickly when an
animal rights person and they would not
be able to deal with receiving all the
health certificates on which health
certificates are now required of them
for various key functions by law the
department is run primarily on user fees
making it hard to budget for capital
expenses like creating a new database
the bill came two ways and means in our
capacity as the overseer
of dedicated funds it borrows from two
funds one closely related and one not to
establish a computerized database for
all animal health records and
which may in the future be expanded to
add other functions these two funds one
for animal feeds and scales mostly
animal feeds and the other for
integrated pest management accumulated
surplus is over several years because
the department did not fully staff the
functions now fully staffed they do not
need those surpluses to operate for the
foreseeable future the database shall be
developed borrowing funds from these
surpluses and be maintained over time
from a new fee of $2 or less on
certificates of health and rabies
vaccinations the department believes
that the veterinarians current costs of
time forms and postage exceed this fee
the committee amendment directs the
repayment of the donor funds first to
the integrated pest management which is
about plants not animals and then to the
animal feed fund it specifies the timing
and direction of all the transfers at
the request of the first committee in
the department it allows customers the
customers certificate copies also to be
digital digital so that they would not
have to receive a paper copy if they do
not want one
finally it sends a five year limit after
the database goes live on transfers to
avoid any further borrowing between
funds is them on represent Sam bird has
his hand up yes ma'am can you hear me
yes madam chair I have a different
opinion on House bill 16:27
FN the amendment done oh you've done a
quality job working drafting the
amendment for the sponsors and the
Commissioner of Department of
Agriculture if this bill were just about
raising money through a fee for the
compiling and administrating of
certificates of vaccinations for city
town and clerks to access to an own
database that is already operational
within the Department of
culture I would find no objection to
supporting this bill but I feel that the
cart is before the horse this is a
capital improvement program request that
I believe should have been first
submitted through the state's capital
funding program procedure the proposal
for this house ways and means committee
to develop short or long term capital
expenditures for any department of this
state I do not believe is this
committees responsibility this database
that the Department of Agriculture and
sponsors want for this record retention
should be should be shouldered by the
state's Capital Improvement Fund process
not the owners who must get a health
certificate rabies vaccination license
information for pet vendors and etc my
two basic objections are this bill has
put the onus upon the House Ways and
Means Committee to resolve an
infrastructure deficiency that should
have been addressed by the New Hampshire
Commissioner of the Department of
Agriculture through a State Capital
Improvement Fund request state
infrastructure requests are more than
just roads vehicles and buildings this
committee has not been informed or shown
that a request to move the Department of
Agriculture into the 21st century was
initiated and what was the response from
the powers to be if there was such a
request my second objection is that I
find great displeasure with the language
that the Commissioner of the Department
of Agriculture is not being required to
reimburse the transferred monies from
the agricultural product and scale
testing fund and the integrated pest
management fund at the end of five years
the use of the word may page 2 line 6 of
the amendment puts no responsibility
upon the commissioner to make whole
again the agricultural product and scale
testing fund or the integrated pest
management fund by the end of year five
and that brings me to this one sub point
the Commissioner during the public
hearing also implied other confusing
cloudy potential financial disclosures
within
the administrating of the department why
hasn't the Commissioner over the last
two year period asked for an audit to
clear up any confusing financial fund
estimates with an unclear financial
picture within the Department of
Agriculture and not requiring repayment
to the agricultural product and scale
testing fund and the integrated pest
management fund a Pandora's Box will be
have been created I find that I cannot
support this bill thank you madam chair
thank you that it is quite a long
statement and part of it is for the
entire bill not the amendment but I
guess we can discuss it now
unfortunately there seems to be nobody
in the attendees that is from the
department or the the Agriculture
Committee right now if I'm wrong I'd
like one of them to raise their hands I
just offered that if one of them is
calling by phone the raised hand
function is star nine one of them is
Club trying to call by phone if that's
the case I just saw a number of polymers
hmm well while we're waiting to see if
we can get I thought that they were
going to be here they may have not
realized that it moved to one o'clock
yes Jess Sanders hasn't stand up and I
was going to go to him next while we're
waiting
thank you madam chairman and I'm always
impressed with the thought that
representative Schamberg puts into his
positions he says a lot in his first
point relative to this being a capital
investment and that probably should have
gone through the do ite and all and gosh
I wish we would have had an opportunity
to talk about that when we were sort of
talking about the
amendment face-to-face because it's an
interesting topic I'm probably still
going to vote YES for this amendment but
I wanted to voice another concern since
we were face to face I've had a number
of people start to share with me their
very strong concerns about vaccine
registries and mandatory vaccines and
all of that and I think if I it had an
opportunity knowing what I know now I
would have asked for the additional line
and the amendment that this IT system
shall not be used to store any human
personal health information but that
that moment has passed I'm gonna vote
YES on the amendment YES on the bill but
I did want to just kind of get it at
least on the record with you all that I
am I'm concerned about these two things
thank you thank you I'm going to try to
reach the Commissioner who apparently is
not on here
you
in the process of trying to get all of
this straight I managed I think actually
I had his cell phone number from when he
was was a member of this committee a
long time ago hi commissioner Jasper I
am okay but we are in executive session
on 1627 and we've had quite a lot of
questions put at us by representative
Schamberg and apparently nobody
representing agriculture or the
Agriculture Committee is on yes yeah yes
I understand that Jim yes can you
Commissioner Jasper should call in order
to join this meeting he'll have there's
a series of numbers I could email the
the directions to him
are you in Commissioner Joseph yeah he's
in his office so that would work to
email them to him
I'm afraid that representing Schamberg
read quite a long statement so I'm not
sure if we're going to have to require
him to repeat it once you're on yeah
why don't you get on it now try
synthesized them and then he can say if
there was something else okay
thanks thank you okay
we're going to have to I would like to
just say this agency is
almost entirely user fees and I believe
that the problem would be that the user
fees would have to be raised in order to
pay for this database and since the
database won't be up and running yet
there the money would have to at least
provisionally be brought in from the
general fund to pay for for the the
capital budget expense reducing the
amount of money that's available for the
general expenses of the state and I
believe that it's in primarily user fees
because it provides principally for the
agricultural sector which is lamentably
a lot smaller than it used to be in the
state of New Hampshire but represent
over Romney and
just a question for my friend I
represent Shambo please
three issues that you have with the bill
we've had a couple of work sessions on
this maybe not on the bill we had a work
session on it not necessary on this
amendment but did you did you bring
these points up before or is this more
reflection over time now that you you've
concluded these things because you know
we have we had a work session just the
other week and how many of these did you
bring up as issues well yes I'm waiting
for to be unmuted here okay on March 5th
appreciate your questions
March 5th the Commissioner had made a
statement about financial confusion and
trying to figure out how much money
there was and I had asked the question
about the financial figures in the
department so it was brought and this
other position I have taken about the
being a capital improvement I didn't ask
the Commissioner that but the more I
looked at the bill it is what it's
becoming as a capital improvement
program I was just reading my opinion
here I don't know if it'll change
anybody's view but I thought I would
state what my objections to this bill
are thank you thank you
yes I think the Commissioner and we
still don't seem to have him in they can
I cannot remember can anyone remember
when the Commissioner became
Commissioner Chris Chris do you remember
that you're in here Chris Shea
you must've Oh Chris I'm sorry rips of
all me I didn't hear the question
the Commissioner became commissioner he
stepped down from speaker to do it I
don't he's been there a couple of years
now but I don't remember how long mm-hmm
the state certainly before he arrived
the state of the finances of the
Agriculture Department where were rather
complicated shall we say and essentially
what they've been doing for many years
is to to try to exist on a minimal very
minimal amount of money and that means
sharing staff time over programs it
means doing without a lot of things the
rest of the departments have represented
Edwards I see her hello a lot of hands
are up Nelson grabs an of Edwards oh
you're a muted look I just wanted to
answer your question I believe it was
mmm
fairly early in 2019 because we were
halfway through the previous term AHA
and that's the answer to your question I
believe and then I just wanted to thank
representative Shamburger again he said
it was just his opinions but the opinion
on the the capital investment I think
it's just really a great point and maybe
we discussed it but it's certainly an
important thing for us to be comfortable
with so so thank you on representative
Tucker's the only one left with a hand
up now
I believe that the Commissioner became
commissioner in January 2019 sorry this
is the Commissioner again hello it's it
just came in okay good
Thanks okay he just got the email and I
represent Tucker I believe the
Commissioner became commissioner in
January of 2019
it's been about here in three months or
less since he was testifying to us on
the bill between those two times yeah
okay so he should be here any minute
the RIP rips not follow me I looked it
up
um represent jazz excuse me Commissioner
Jasper became the Commissioner November
22nd 20 17 18 20 22
you said he became commissioner in
November of 17 yep and his term expires
in November of 2022 five-year term
mm-hmm so that's even further back
considerably further back
on upstairs she wants to say something
again yes madam chair yes I think it
caused all this confusion I'm just
stating my opinion and I thought we
would be moving on then to vote on your
motion to approve this amendment
well they've raised several questions
that I think people want the answers to
[Music]
Commissioner is on the line and he's oh
yes good o attendees has gone up but
could you let could you just let him you
ready oh there he is good on
Commissioner Jasper on the main points
that represent of Shambu raised were
that on this should have gone to a
request to the capital Budget Committee
on first and should include going this
is from representative Edwards that it
should have gone through on on the
Department of Information Technology and
that on representative Schamberg also
wants the full repayment to be made by
the end of the five years and says that
that you would said yourself that the
finances of the department are on still
in disarray and he felt that that this
ought to be postponed I think in order
to to get the finances in array and have
a chance to talk to the capital budget
Kamini okay thank you thank you for the
questions I you know we didn't believe
that it should go as a capital request
because we were able to to self fund it
and they the likelihood of this
competing with all the other capital
needs of the state I just I didn't feel
that we would have any chance of success
given the directives that has have come
down so we were trying to do this
through creative financing I don't
believe that I said that the state of
the department's finances were in
disarray I I think what I what I said
was that there seemed to be a lack of
balance and one of the accounts but that
there's plenty of money there and we
were working on that I what I told you
was that more money was being drawn
against that than seemed to be coming in
but with the with the staffing that we
have been allowed to have that actually
is getting better every month but
nonetheless in that account and the
other account there's plenty of money
and the other account is actually
building up more quickly than it should
be in terms of paying it back in five
years the fee would have to be much
higher to do that but as I said in the
last meeting that you had where I spoke
there is a real nexus to the to the pet
food part of this and so I'm very
comfortable with this fee this money
coming out of that that account even if
it isn't paid back and that's why I
think we talked about the fact that if
in fact we had to use any money from the
pesticides account that would be paid
paid back first but I don't need to take
money out of the pesticide fund not sure
if that's number two everything so a lot
of questions there but yeah have you
talked to is
do IT about how you do this yeah yeah we
have talked to do IT mainly in terms of
the security issues on there and the
fact that they will be one of the
vendors if you will who will be bidding
on this in all likelihood although I
have to tell you we're we're doing
another program that was a should have
been online last year through do IT and
for those of you been around a while if
you remember when we were changing over
the program for the house the system
crashed a couple times one right in the
middle of vote and that it was described
as putting a square peg in a round hole
we are in the same problem with the
weights and measures program right now
that do IT is actually doing for us it's
just not an off-the-shelf program you
really for some of these things need to
go to a company that is more specialized
but do IT is aware of this we've spoken
with them about it
they'll be taking a look at it once and
they'll no doubt will be a critical part
of putting together the the request for
proposal at that time thank you
does do we have anyone who wants to ask
further questions or I don't see any
hands being raised raised in the
committee representative I you have to
unmute episode Tucker sorry we have the
Commissioner on hand it would be nice to
have him have a chance to just give two
or three sentences of why this is an
important project thank you a little way
from that
thank you and I had a if I may madam
chairman yes yeah I actually had a long
conversation with a state senator this
weekend about about that and the reality
is the legislature has asked us to or
instructed us to run this pet bending
program and we cannot do it to the
extent that we've been asked to without
a whole lot of more personnel or without
this program and obviously we don't even
have the space to house the personnel or
the documents that we're being asked to
to collect so for the legislature to say
that we need to register everyone who is
breeding 25 dogs cats ferrets etc not to
mention all the fish and everything else
in here we have to have this program and
as I have been saying right right from
the beginning of this it is it's not
fair to the department to ask us to do a
job and then not give us the resources
to do it in this particular case I
didn't ask the legislature to give us
the funding to do what you asked us to
do I came up with a creative way to fund
it with in-house recognizing the
limitations of the state finances which
of course are much worse now than when
this when this started so we've tried to
be responsive in all ways to what the
legislature has asked us to do but we
simply cannot do the job without this
program thank you I'd like to add that
the pit then the vendor program was
inserted by the Senate in to HB 4 you
are correct any further questions or
comments representative Romney
you know let's not lose sight of that
there this is the second coming he bill
but the policy we're talking about was
approved by I guess the Agriculture
Commission and what we're weighing in on
is we're the guardians of the dedicated
funds as you mentioned earlier
representative army and all we're doing
here is giving an approval to dip into
those two funds that's what I thought is
it up to this point I think we've all
agreed that that was okay to do I know
this is the final vote but we haven't
heard any real negative comments about
doing that up to this point
thank you thank you any further comments
from the committee then the clerk will
call the roll on amendment 12:54 H on
earth ought to pass on the amendment
representative Eames
represented aims observe aims ah you are
there I do my vote is yes sorry for the
muting problem
representative Carrick yes
representative Southworth yeah is he
still on yes clerk vote yes
representative Schamberg no presentative
Tucker yes representative bunker yes
Seneca Marlow yes representative
Griffith ahead of Griffith website good
fix are you there
you seem sure stepped away
I requested unmute a few times I with
that response representative Stram yes
of sedative major yes
representative Griffin yeah presented
Valerie
represented Valerie okay yeah I was
waiting for the unmute to show up
yes thank you representing a bra me yes
representative Lang represent language
yes beside of dissent yeah Edwards
something I know but the problem is the
central muting and unmuting is
problematic yes you represent a bursting
yes was any of all me yes vote is 17 yes
one no and one not voting thank you it's
a vote being seventeen to one amendment
12 54 passes I would like to move sick
House bill 1627 as amended by on and
then 12 54 H is there a second
thank you seconded House bill 16:27 f.n
amended by amendment 12 54 H is moved by
a volley seconded by representative
Brahmi and is there any further
discussion I don't see any hands raised
so the clerk will call the roll for
ought to pass on House bill 1627 amended
by 1254 H representative Ames
yes
representative Carrick yes is any
Southworth yes well it's yes
representing Schamberg representing
Schamberg know the unmuting is not quick
enough I'll slow down obscenity of
Tucker
yes there was any bunker yes
representative demarlo yes
representative Griffith still the way to
string him yes
representative major yes is that it
Griffin
yes yes yes yes representing Edwards yes
first
no
presented all may yes vote on 1627
autopass is amended with amendment
number one - five four - h16 yes - no
and one not voting thank you
on the motion of ought to pass with
amendment 12 54 H 416 27f and passes on
the vote of 16 to 2 is there an
objection to the consent calendar I
don't see any hands up then it will go
on consent thank you
that finishes our executive session and
Thank You Commissioner for joining us we
are the committee is going to stay you
know perhaps before you move out of the
exact I'm not sure I'm sorry to
interrupt
yes what did you want to do before then
oh well it can't be if we don't know if
we're on the consent calendar and I ask
that does anybody want to just be a
minor reporter Bianca said you can't
have a minority report on consent now
anybody who wants to see a minority
report want to Tom Sandberg has his hand
up now on representing schanberg yes I'm
waiting for to be unmuted can you hear
me
yes I appreciate my good friend from
strata
do you want to volunteer for the
Minority Report Idol okay would you like
to do are you saying yes I said no thank
you no thank you
okay so do I hear any objection to the
consent calendar we will go with a
consent calendar thank you
so we are going to reform ourselves I've
got to put away the exec council papers
exec committee session papers and
collect my my revenue papers again it
will take me one minute on is anybody
else need a longer break and we this
executive session is ended and we will
reconvene in one minute as the revenue
estimating session Susan yes can Chris
put up the numbers okay why don't you
put up page one and then we can look at
page two after that just Chris there
Chris did you hear that yeah thanks
thank you
I did hear my dogs are barking so I
stayed muted for a second longer
Jim could you tell us on do we have to
call a roll again when we go back into
exec when you're restarting the revenue
you mean yes it's my understanding since
you did it earlier that you should be
all set okay yes we may I think we have
representative Griffith with us now who
wasn't here then well we've got his
picture I don't know if he's behind it
not getting a response yeah so I I guess
we don't have to do that
represent a major you can just tell us
when you want to move to the next screen
represented go Marlo has her hand up I
can't see them now I'm gonna have to
there we go I want to tell you I need to
leave at about 20 to quarter of an
appointment okay we may be able to make
that if we go along at the pace we were
doing before we had to break for the
executive session quicker we're taking
the agency numbers but multiplying law
for two thousand which is one thirty
point one and one thirty one point one
correct and and all we did on the first
year is rounded down to 130 and the
second year we rounded down to 131 but
we went up to 134 because the liquor
commissioner was telling us that total
spirits I think that's what it's called
is
has switched to what a second stage
usually is in coming into new territory
in Massachusetts and raised their prices
there so that they are no longer
competitive with us in a number of items
for the price and we thought that this
would probably bring us back some people
from Massachusetts but we only we went
up three percent now as curious why
didn't he go up why didn't he go up I
think that that he presented this this
argument about coming about possibly
being able to be more competitive with
them again in in the Massachusetts
market market but we didn't ask him
about whether he would go up be willing
to go up because of that
on his estimate on it there's also the
issue that I believe represented major
and I talked about at one point that his
his numbers as they are for 21
I believe include 2.7 million I didn't
think so no no he took he took out the
2.7 million in the second year for the
sale of the property that they could not
sell this year but that they have out to
bid right now to do in July or August
and he believes that the bid there
they've been a number of legitimate
bidders who looks like they were going
to be pretty good and that they'd be
able to get their price if they did that
then the 131 point
one would go up to 133 point 8 in the
second year and that money represents
how much they have to pay on an annual
bond that they would be paying off
enough of the bonds that they could
could pay two point seven million less
they had originally included in their
plan that they were going to be able to
make make that sale this year and it
hasn't happened that's it's dedicated to
the bond payment then it would be yes I
could respond to that yes though what
they're suggesting to you is because
you're in the liquor fund mm-hmm having
an expense of 2.7 million you'd have
that revenue coming in from the sale
that would offset what they had earlier
when they did the budget hit projected
was gonna be 2.7 million dollars of debt
service payments so in a sense you gain
that 2.7 in your revenue yes because the
revenue that we see is net of all of
their expenses correct and and the sale
of this of this land was something that
was negotiated after or separate from
the budget it's kind of outside that
process of the revenue estimates that
we're done originally and that's correct
no I'm okay with that range I'm
representative Romney has his hand up
you know my father call our discussions
in our caucus we decided we would go
back and forth on this one what what to
do about 2.7 million is that we said
that lets the street has found money if
it happens take the more conservative
approach because there's still an
outside shot that the deal may not
happen so that happens happening so so
that's why we took the more conservative
view that's that's correct but we are
looking at a range here so I'd like and
and there's also the total spirits
question on that within the range well
it would fit within the range that we
proposed but you didn't propose a range
so is there anybody else that wants to
add something then will will vote for
liquor on revenues in 2008 twenty one
hundred and thirty million and in FY or
do you want to do 0.1 or just leave it
at 130 on 130 yeah
in FY 2130 million and in FY 21 131 to a
hundred thirty-four million yes so the
clerk will call the roll for the liquor
estimate at FY 2130 million and FY 21 a
low of 100
31 and a high of 134 representative
Eames yes yes
representative Carrick yeah isn't it at
Southworth yeah
clerk quotes yes that Schamberg yes
representative Tucker yes
representative bunker yes and of gamar
low yes Zeb Griffith representative
string him yes
representative major yes
representative Griffin yes
representative Oliver yes
Susanna Brahmi yes representative Lang
representative just set yes
representative Edwards yes is that it
bursting yes represent of all me yes 17
yes 0 no and to not voting thank you
on we have represent Lori's hand up for
some reason website Valerie did you want
to yeah I just got a email from one of
my contacts and law enforcement
regarding tomorrow oh sorry on so if
they aware Manchester in Nashville
tomorrow
well liquor and the vote being 17 to 0
the motion passes for liquor revenues
and an FY 20 at 130 million and in FY 21
as low of 131 and a high of 134 we've
got that put in and the next one is
lottery we've managed to group the sin
taxes together and we do have somewhat
bigger difference but on this one we all
take the the lottery commissioners on
estimates of 95 for 20 and 100 for 21 on
as as the base we on our side have gone
up five million to a
hundred as the high for fy2010 up ten to
110 for FY 21 and it had to do with on
Charley McEntire not including in his
estimates from what he was saying at any
rate the opening sports opportunities
that are showing up or the scratch
ticket boom which so far is a boomlet we
don't know how long it will go
so that's but the sports betting had
been pretty much closed down by kovat
and they seem to be getting back on
their feet again so anyone want to say
something about about the difference
between the highs on those to observe
ami reps and the Brahmi has his hand up
absent of a Brahmi every time you put up
the spreadsheet I lose the yeah let's go
with let's go 21 first so you're hiring
assumes that we would get too close to
the original plan which I don't know how
that's gonna happen I mean I mean sure
he's not gonna be open for a while but
that's a very small number I know
restaurants are opening slow we know
they're gonna continue to all Bend and
that that's the key no money I don't
know I don't think we're gonna I don't
think we're gonna get up to 110 I mean
we could probably have something in but
for that but now the waiter 110 I don't
think so I think we compromised on that
and then the else calls make expect the
difference but that's my thoughts I just
don't know how to get to win tonight and
I know what happened to boat like you
said and scratch tickets but that could
just be a phenomenon of of the colvett
situation that we have no explanation
for but the tickets aren't selling that
are the Mega Millions and Powerball
pretty significant revenue for us so I
mean I'm not compromising on this one
but if you represent a major would you
like to propose something different or
comic my comment similar to what Pat I
said to compromise somewhat on 21 but
not to 110 this is again a function of
I'd rather stay closer to the 100 I
would bring if I put a range on it let
me push it like going to 105 to do as
far as year 20 what the difference
something like 95 to 97 yes he did in
his report to us say that it's 95 and a
hundred but then he says that major
sports are beginning earlier than we
thought will be that that being said a
few other factors must be recognized
meaning that they aren't in his estimate
that major sports will begin prior to
September 1 and that Mega Millions
rolling jackpot is going to you know
significant revenues if it continues to
roll I don't follow it so I don't know
and the this boomlet in scratch tickets
which are usually very predictable but
of course we that would be showing up
this year but in next and next month's
revenues
I don't know Chris do you know what the
end of May is for lottery their number
wouldn't have changed from what you saw
earlier in the dailies right yeah so I
just wanted to weigh in in support of a
compromise that's been suggested so I
believe 95 to 97 as a range in 2020 and
105 and 21 seems reasonable to me okay
I'm reps I've Tucker Tucker immunity
yeah so it seems very reasonable to me I
think that's a good compromise that boat
all right is there any further
discussion then the clerk will call the
roll
on lottery revenues FY 2000 of 95 high
of 97 FY 21 low of 100 I of 105
representative Ames yes
% of Carrick yes
representative Southworth yeah
clerk votes yes represent of Schamberg
yes
so one muted Tucker yes
scented bunker I didn't hear response
yes yes presented Griffith instead of
string of me yes
is that a major yes was that of Griffin
yeah comes end of all already yes
presented a bra me yes
I'm sending Lang presented to set yes
his end of Edwards yes incentive
bursting yes does any of all me yes Oh
17 yes zero knows and to not voting
thank you the movie 17 to Cyrano the
motion for on lottery revenues in FY
2006 95 hi 97 and in 21 low of a hundred
high of a hundred and five passes and
had been put into the lottery column now
now we've finished with with the regular
spreadsheet for the general fund and the
Education Trust Fund the total numbers
that we've got seem to be two billion
four hundred and twenty seven million
point three to two million five hundred
and one million point three in twenty
and in 21 two million two hundred and
sixty one low to two billion four
hundred and twenty seven point one nine
and it's really nice to be able for all
of us to see those before it gets turned
into a green sheet for for the hall
so I hope we can continue to do this
once we get back to meeting in person
again then we have the highway fund Oh
should we take we can take a vote on the
whole thing in the end right so you got
rips of majors hand is up and represent
oh I'm sorry his hands are up
I lose the hands every time you put up a
split screen and forget to put them back
major Chris you'll send you email these
sheets to us yeah absolutely so good so
when you're done your work today I will
make these available to everybody on the
committee I'll send them out to you all
and I can also send the excel sheet as
well you know on make it available
online on the general court website good
I had a comment I'm just thrilled that
the ways and means remained able to
negotiate and be bipartisan I attributed
that a lot to our Chairman and
representative pager getting together
and others but really it's a great thing
when you see so many other units of
government unable to even be civil to
each other much less work together and
the organization that went into this
meeting between the staffs and the
leadership really is outstanding and I
just wanted to comment on that before we
log down into Fish and Game and
transportation I don't think will bog
down
I want to write to the end to thank they
will just so we don't lose any more
people before we go Highway worksheet if
we can get to that we have I wanted to
take just three votes and miscellaneous
it can be added in if we want to motor
vehicle fees that sounds good with me
yes so so the first one is the road toll
which is the largest single source that
that was put in by the agency as a
hundred fourteen point seven for 2020
and the Republicans and the Democrats
went from a range of a hundred and
fifteen which is a hundred and fourteen
point seven rounded to a hundred and
seventeen very small range for 2020 and
in FY 21 the agency 115 point six and
the Republicans mirrored it and the
Democrats raised it to 118 low and a
hundred and twenty-five I now I believe
that basically we did that because every
day that we go out on the roads now we
see more and more cars
getting back on the roads those cars on
the highways and cars in our local areas
and and it does seem that the opening
for in terms at least of driving to the
supermarket and driving out to a piece
of country where you can calm down a
little bit and be be isolated but but I
in nature is expanding a fair amount the
parks are having trouble with too many
people trying to come in in some places
at least and we also think that it will
will increase a lot faster on the basis
of that but not too to the original
level that the highway fund had been
expected to reach of a hundred and
thirty-two but about halfway up to that
beautiful during during the year quicker
than it shows and the especially in the
second half of the year that day of the
term the fiscal year the first part of
then it shows in their monthly revenue
numbers that we were all sent but we
were sent as a PDF and
I took those numbers I took those
numbers manually into a Excel
spreadsheet I hope in the future we can
get these things not in the PDF but
we've never had these before so we have
no historical review of how much they
differ from months to months and what
they've done with that but we have
through April at least what this is in a
much more detail than we can get when
we're looking at a chart in the back of
the revenue focus and the july to
february road toll average for 2020 that
is july 19 to February 20 was 10.8 $7
million dollars per month 37 which is a
little bit higher than the official plan
was for this year but this is not a
normal year and and in March the numbers
started to go down and in April they
were down a fair amount but we're all
seeing a lot more people in May coming
back on the roads not anywhere near
natural normal yet but enough so that we
felt we could go up to at least a
hundred and seventeen on that
by the end of this year and road toll 21
what there she shows us is that they do
not expect to see normality in the road
toll until June of next year
and before that it will be varying up
and down as the months do but the
average from June to may July - July 22
May 21 for Road toll they have as an
average of 1.3 million dollars lower
than the average then we had before
coated this year and so so that Apple is
I only did these numbers after we had
our caucus but we'd we'd done a a on
view of it just generally by eye during
the caucus and had decided to put the
numbers up a little for the first year
and and then up more in the second year
then then the ten ten million more
almost and then the second year estimate
because unless we have a major
recurrence resurgence of the virus
almost equal to what we had this time
the traffic should continue reps involve
me you've got three questions rips
himself yes Graham Center Southwest
first thank you yes thank you madam
chair and I remember the discussion in
caucus as I sit here today
I find I'm leaning a lot more towards
the agency estimate
I think the tolls will probably drop at
least 10% because just in talking with
people I think there'll be less trips by
New Hampshire residents I think people
just are feeling they need to stay put
really for a while I also think they're
going to be certainly less tourists so
when I look at that 1:32 and plan I
think it may drop at least 10% at least
for one year it's kind of where I'm
leaning at this moment okay so maybe
slightly higher than the agency estimate
but not by much
I just think I'm just hearing from
people that they're really changing some
of their plans these are for longer
trips yes or even do short trips not as
often people are talking about not going
to the beach as much or you know
different things like that it's just
what I'm hearing okay
and it may be different in different
parts of the state because definitely in
our part of the state
we've got more traffic there is more but
I still think it might be 10% less than
the original well that's 10% for June if
we're talking about 2020 no I was
talking about 2021 oh okay okay so 10%
less would be 13 from 1:30 to around 118
and then Lexus
absitively Brahmi and all I can tell you
is that you lost and half the license
plates were from Massachusetts in Maine
most in Massachusetts so things are
picking up yes hand up next
okay Webb said major thank you you gotta
remember that the agency came up with
114 million dollars for FY 21 about
three and a half months of reduce gas
taxes mm-hmm and then looking at 2021
you're gonna have reduced gas taxes
maybe not at the rate that we had in
April or May but it's going to be over a
period of a whole year and my feeling is
that we need to take down 532 by at
least 11% such as what the agency and I
think they did that job while 11% would
be 14
14.5 I guess but that the agency took it
down further than that yeah 15.6 is not
much difference uh no no 14.5 and that's
170 117 point point 7 I think 6 whatever
you're getting down to the range and I
think that this will blow up if we don't
come back and a steady stream if we we
have disruptions a second wave or third
wave doesn't get worse because now we're
dealing with a whole year who has the
reduce travel rather than just and then
you have to figure it's always like
about a month behind so it's really two
and a half months or so so I think you
gotta be careful ok people in other
parts of the state Reps and berstein has
his hands up reps involve me oh oh yes
I'm sad bursting thank you actually I
just want to relay a message from
representative Edwards his home network
fresh rejoin us I didn't hear that
website of Edwards home network crashed
and he's trying to get back all so I'm
wondering if people who are having
different experiences in different parts
of the state because we're getting
to the point where were the Bell I'd say
70 percent normal at this point in our
traffic and it came back really quickly
in this in this month in May in last
month 70 percent versus that's that's
one month looking at it but you might
have a reduction and over time will you
think that it will stay once it starts
to come back it will plant Oh again I am
hopeful that it doesn't exceed 11
percent total for the whole year we know
that coming into ROM now was about
thirty five percent at the toll gates 40
percent toll gates the toll gates were
less last week they were down to 37
percent loss I think it was no it was
come it was falling dead the loss was
falling down considerably from one week
to the next for a couple of weeks the
protection I don't know what this
weekend was if it takes a year to fall
only 5% you take the average over the
year and it's gonna be overall of nickel
size but it doesn't it didn't take a
year to fall fibers anyway okay it fell
dramatically like a step function yeah
right but I mean the loss has been
falling considerably in one week to the
next
each weekends tolls it's not gonna come
back as a step function yeah yeah okay
grab set of Tucker
yes I think the whole tourism part of
the economy is going to be affected all
summer and fall thank you things are
being canceled in a big way our fishing
game Department is asked the White
Mountain National Forest not to open up
Tuckerman Ravine for example or annex
for two weeks because they're afraid of
injuries that might drain their staff
and all kinds of things are still being
canceled I need a what they're talking
about canceling almost all their events
and hikes organized hikes for the summer
and people aren't playing to come who
usually come here for two weeks two
months so I think we're going to see
really substantial change in each
segment of the state represent a Maui
commerce team no Swami I've said
bursting had his hand up thank you I'm
sure I can to agree with all these
comments I would considered New
Hampshire fortunate if we only eroded
10% next year I think representative
Southworth gave the number 10 percent
but presented a major 11 percent if at
the end of fiscal 2021 but that's where
we are not only we have their tourism
concerns but there's been such
dislocation to the economy it makes
sense that we're going to see that's
less traffic look at our unemployment
rate right now to me at a minimum
percent to go maybe 15 but I think
that's that's the range I'm working in
the floor of 10 or 11 percent
my only comment okay on so next year
we're talking if we're talking about 10
percent or talking at one 13.2 off of
132 points free that would be around 119
we can make that the midpoint the 119
make that the midpoint
range and I think I think that would
solve the problem
would that be acceptable to others and
had 119 as the number for FY I mean yeah
something like that
it could 116 to 122 would be three in
either direction of that Yeah right I
did I'm sorry
and is that acceptable on to people
because it starts above
well it doesn't start above the rounded
number for the the highway people the
safety people so what you're saying is
21 would be 116 to 123 22 say it again
Oh 21 would be 116 low to 122 hi
my my ever thought as I look at that now
maybe maybe bring it down a million each
maybe 115 to 120 long something like
that yeah has his hand up
yes I feel better with the 115 to 120
one and this year could we say 114 to
116 or why not what do people want why
not I thought their beam is lower than
theirs and ours yeah it is no 115 why
not 115 yeah okay just one number yes
any further thoughts then the clerk will
call the roll for road tolls from the
for the highway fund on in FY 2100 and
15 million in FY 21 115 low 221 high 121
high
this is for the road toll of the highway
fund I represented names yes kind of
caring yes
representative Southworth yes quarter
for chess representing Schamberg yes
obscenity of Tucker yes any bunker yes
zennith demarlo oh I think she had to
leave you forever it's me representative
Griffith mmm
stirring him yes that have major yes
presented Griffin yeah isn't it of all
reading yes presenter of a bra me
yes representative Lang representative
just set
representative set symmetry said it
looks like he's here and he's unmuted so
he may have stepped away okay
representative Edwards yes represented
bursting yes there's no mommy yes
what is fifteen yes no nose and for not
voting thank you the vote being 15 to
zero the emotion for road toll and the
highway fund FY 2150 115 million and FY
21 a range from 115 to 120 1 million
passes on we now have the only other
fees ranges in in the highway fund
grouped as motor vehicle fees they
mostly are motor vehicle fees there's no
money that came in from sales or planned
for next year of sales of vehicles so
the department had estimated that we
would end 20 with on with motor vehicle
fees up to 124 point seven and we the
Democrats had looked at that and I hope
someone else remembers our arguments for
this I can't find any papers that deal
with this problem it's probably written
on one of our documents but we thought
that it was likely to come in lower than
this probably we
had a low of 115 million and a high of
125 million in on 21 the department had
a number of 119 point three million and
the Democrats looked at it and thought
that it might go as low as 118 and up to
123 so focusing around a million more
than then they were saying we do know
that the motor vehicle fees go down next
year about five million I think because
we're in the fifth year next year of a
transformation that's been going on for
two decades now I think in which we went
from a four year license to a five year
license and the fifth year drops off so
I need to get back my participant list
we don't have a hand up yet I'm going to
try to form our caucus report except
that there isn't anything written after
it
so is there anyone else that can help me
out
on this as to why we thought they were
too high the first year and not high
enough to sit in here
I can't remember at this point we
understood the highway funds at the very
end when we're getting tired we got
anybody in attendees yeah you have rep
some of Romney and reps of Ames and
major all with your hands up now oh they
just put them up as I moved over to
attendees a brawny
week eight web surveys first ago she was
on the committee of poem has to
recollection of your logic the logic
James do you I'm sorry Patrick I do not
have a recollection
I'd say under the circumstances and the
Nate the course this have that we should
rally around the agency number ok I
concur that's a or something we the
trouble is we only get this from the
revenue focus we don't get breakdown and
any time until we can we can we just
have that one vitamin when we asked for
it this last time we got a monthly
spreadsheet which is for the road toll
because that's what we'd asked oh no
it's further Oliver
but I only analyzed the road tool
because it was a lot took a lot of time
to enter it all into an Excel
spreadsheet in the future we really I
think I've asked for this to have more
detail in the past and and they didn't
want to to make the monthly revenue plan
a monthly revenue focus longer so they
aren't doing it but but maybe they could
provide it to us then we can ask in a
way that we can look at it so because
this revenue is really important to
their activities but on so if we take
the agency estimates for these in the
first year it's a hundred and twenty
four point seven and in the second year
it's a hundred and twenty nine hundred
and nineteen point three
and we have nobody here from the
highways so I guess we're going to just
have to take their estimates so that is
is find we also have to have the costs
of collection as they have revised them
I knew no I looked at those just the
other day but now I can't find them
again
yes it's Chris
yes you don't need to concern yourself
with the cost of collections at this
time you use it okay through column D so
you do gross yeah and then the cost of
collections is netted after the fact
reasons on on the schedule before you is
that if somebody were to go back to the
official revenue plan for 2020 seven
point six and that's because they
deducted the 31.8 in cost of collections
your estimates it was two fifty nine
point four okay good because they didn't
change their cost of collections also
they lowered them so so all we have to
do is vote on the we don't have to vote
on the net sum because it is it follows
directly so we'll vote to accept I wish
we could get the data that caused us to
do this but vote to accept their numbers
for the motor vehicle fees as a group
for in FY 20
one hundred twenty four point seven
million and in FY 21 a hundred and
nineteen point three million reps
involve me mm-hmm
could you also include the miscellaneous
in the vote that you're going to taste
including the miscellaneous so that's
gonna stay at the point two point two
four nine two so this will be one twenty
four point nine will just say the
missile and the miscellaneous four point
two each year yes thank you so the clerk
will call the roll for a motor vehicle
fines in twenty at one twenty four point
seven and twenty one 119 point three and
miscellaneous each year at point two oh
he does okay I'm Sam thirsty yeah thank
you I just got a text from
representative Edwards thing the power
just went out at their house so Edwards
is absent at this point I hope he gets
his power back okay
to be clear put this all on one sheet
one hundred twenty four point seven or a
vehicle feet twenty one 19.3 motor
vehicle fees for twenty one and point
two
miscellaneous fees for 20 and point to
miscellaneous fees for 21 exactly yes
representative Eames yes is that a
carrot yes representative Southworth yes
clerk votes yes
[Music]
Tucker okay
she seems to have disappeared okay
[Music]
representing bunker yes representative
Gemara oh I think she's gone to
obscenity of Griffith then if string him
yes that a major yes
representative Griffin yeah then of
already yes bra me yes and I just also
got the text from Jess I think I'm done
for the committee today
eversource says the power won't come
back into 415 so clean us presentative
laying decided to set
there's nothing to set is unmuted and he
appears to be here but no response
okay Edwards is representative bursting
yes present all me
yes reluctantly this vote is interesting
it's 13 yeas no nose and 6 not voting so
so being 13 to 0 motor vehicle fees for
the Department for highway fund for
twenty one hundred twenty four point
seven for twenty one of a hundred
nineteen point three plus miscellaneous
fees of point two for each year passes
and I just lost artist offense again so
we've got that there and the only thing
left to do is the fishing game page all
of us decided to agree with the agency I
would like to
proposed for the fishing game funds for
FY 2010 for 4.2 million and we don't
have to do the total and for 2021 for FY
21 the licenses at nine point seven five
million all other at 3.3 million and V
and we'll have to decide how to whether
we round up or down nine nine point
eight million and three point three
million for all other so is there anyone
that wants to change those estimates
round us down on whatever then I'm gonna
cleaned up reps in a major so on FY 21
the licenses would be nine point eight
and the others would be three point five
oh oh oh right three point five sorry
all right
okay yeah yeah and I'm reading from an
old spreadsheet and we've taken them
down slightly for reasons that were
appropriate that I put in
so so call for a vote them on the fifth
game fund licenses in FY 2010 point two
and all other at four point two and then
in FY twenty-one licenses on at nine
point eight and all other at three point
five and the the clerk will call the
roll
on those numbers represented veins yes
is that a Carrick yes Southworth yes
clerk vote yes percent of Schamberg
Hamburg
I didn't hear a comment call him again -
amber somebody has to unmute me what say
you
[Music]
somebody has to unmute me more i muted
we can hear it yes Tucker yeah
missing okay sanity bunker yes
is that if Marlo I think is dead
Griffith is presented locked man
represents string of them yes that major
yes
is that a Griffin yeah little ready yes
does any of a bra me yes
representative Lang is then I've just
set representative bursting that yes was
that of all me yes vote this time is 13
yes 0 no and 5 or so not going thank you
on they vote being 13 to 0 the motion
for Fish and Game revenues of FY 20
lessons is at ten point two and other at
four point two and in FY twenty-one
licenses at nine point eight and other
three point five passes and is getting
filled in okay I think on so I think we
we in the past we have done a formal
final vote on all of the revenues
together have we not
or there's no reason you couldn't do it
as one vote yeah
can everybody see the fishing game and
that I filled it in and they can see the
totals and I can go back through the
worksheets if people want to just see
highway total again and then the general
education trust okay why don't you do
that and then we'll just say as
displayed in the worksheet so if
everybody's all set with Fish and Game
I'll take you to highway and your
revisions resulted in a fiscal 20 of two
thirty nine point nine and a missed call
2021 a range of two thirty four point
five to two forty point five everybody's
all set with that I'll take it to the
general fund education trust fund so for
fiscal year twenty your total your low
total is two four to seven point three
your high total is two five zero one
point three for twenty and for twenty
one it's two to six 1.0 two to four to
7.1 and I get that's fiscal 21 thank you
that's what I had the clerk will call
the roll on the spreadsheet as it exists
right now with totals of twenty four
twenty seven point three to twenty five
zero one point three million in 20 and
twenty two sixty one point zero to
twenty four twenty seven point one in
twenty one
the general and Education Trust Funds
and for the highway fund total it's on
this plane and for the highway toll fun
totals of two hundred thirty nine point
nine million in 20 and two hundred forty
point five million in to a range of two
hundred and thirty four point five to
two hundred and forty point five million
in 21 and the fishing game totals being
on fourteen point four million in twenty
and thirteen point three million in 21
rip said of Malloy representative Ames
yes
Carrick yes presenter Southworth yes
clerk for chess Hamburg yes can you hear
me yep oh great
presented bunker yes there's no good
Marlow representative Griffith
representative string him yes there's
that a major yes then of Griffin yeah
their glory yes that over Brahmi yes
there's any burn lange representative to
set
representative Burstein yes done of all
me
yes it is thirteen yes zero knows and
five not voting thank you very much
the vote being 13 to zero for the final
spreadsheet of the four funds
I think we've completed our work I
wanted to really thank everybody
including those who have had to drop off
towards the end for a pretty long and
exhausting day and for your the ability
that all of us have shown to compromise
with each other and to to create yet
another non partisan revenue estimate
for the house and particularly my
colleagues the games
patrica Brahmi and nor major in perhaps
the river center of importance
so perhaps so I don't know if anybody
else wants to make any kind of other
comments about this we may still be
meeting in executive session another I
hope other sessions after after the 11th
dealing with Senate bills it's going to
depend on whether the Republican caucus
decides to vote against the measure that
that changes our deadlines so that we
can complete this year but I'm very glad
that we have completed this work
absolute of all me you have rep some
major and berstein with their hands up
I'm saying nature oh thank you
I want
representing said you know become good
legislators you have to know how to
negotiate and compromise this committee
as a whole that's showing that and i
sonja appreciated rubs and all the
represented aims abroad me myself and
all the others we know how to negotiate
no friends thank you thank you and rips
are bursting thank you began getting
modeling with you all no she's not here
I would say how appreciative I am be
served on this committee appreciate
brain trust and leadership on both sides
of the aisle all four years are terrific
and I think search ye get two guns and
thank you for that and the staff is just
wonderful Christian and everybody else
caring it's just a privilege to work
Thank You sherry yeah earlier but that
was a serious email message that I got
it's apparently a credible threat to
Manchester and it may or may not spread
to Concord you can more likely hear you
i yeah i'm saying the there's a credible
threat against manchester and maybe
Nashua less likely Concord tomorrow
unknown what time probably the evening
law enforcement is looking for
truckloads of bricks being delivered to
either one of the cities
Rick's great okay you had your hand up
it depends how you vote on extending the
deadlines I'm not sure yes
can negotiate even compromising yes that
would be very good so if it doesn't I
think we're going to try to put out some
kind of press release or something if we
get stopped from continuing on which it
seems to me is not appropriate at this
time because a lot of other bills in the
legislature are nonpartisan also that
are stuck by this but anyway I also I I
forgot and I really shouldn't have
forgotten to include in my thanks the
clerk represent Malloy
he carries a lot of the burden on these
sessions especially revenue estimates
where we had to do all of these votes
Thank You Dennis welcome my pleasure and
thanks to any and all the other supports
that and we have had a lot of
contribution from both of our caucuses
besides the people that I mentioned
so including Jerry string of who on our
site has been running the hosting a lot
of the time so so that's I think that
concludes today's sessions just one
quick comment before you leave yes so as
mentioned earlier I'll send out the
spreadsheet as you saw in the view I'll
send it out as a PDF to each member as
well as an Excel okay posted on the
General Court website so agency
information go to the general court home
page it says Jim in that box you'll see
a link to all the agencies so they'll be
available if for some reason you can't
find them in your files they will be
available online also in which part of
the website in the elbe am so when you
go to the general court homepage mm-hmm
there's a box that says general court
news inside that box you're gonna see a
ways and means link which means link and
that'll take you to the agency documents
from behind and we'll add in the
information from today the other piece
that I just wanted to mention is that
when we're concluded here put the
information together in the format for
your resolution I'll submit it to OLS
they should have that turned around I
don't think they'll get it done today
because I probably won't get it to him
before 4 o'clock 1:30 but they'll have
it something back for you tomorrow
represent so you'll probably be reached
out to by less and that's all I have
okay good thank you and we can once I
get that I can share it around to
everyone to the green sheet it will be
in a form that we haven't seen before do
do them highs and lows I couldn't give
you this if you want I can show a sneak
peak but I think everybody wants to get
going yes I think everybody wants to get
going too
and I just had a phone call from someone
I hung up on in our last meeting because
we were in mating so on thank you all
again very very much
and I'ma Durning this meeting oh and
thank you also to the support staff I
forgot to say that hey guys thanks